sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße es ist er herzlich zur
pressekonferenz mit
verteidigungsminister in klaudia tanner
mit universitätsprofessorin post dr
saskia stachowitsch der
wissenschaftlichen leiterin des
österreichischen instituts für
internationale politik und dem
abteilungsleiter der abteilung militär
diplomatie reagiert dr peter vorhofer
und ich darf die
verteidigungsministerien ersuchen zu
beginnen vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
universitätsprofessorin sehr geehrter
herr brigadier sehr geehrte damen und
herren es ist mir eine ganz besondere
freude ihnen heute unsere publikation
der strategische kompass der
europäischen union ziele perspektiven
und chancen für österreich vorstellen zu
dürfen
lassen sie mich vielleicht eines gleich
vorweg
festhalten
das was sicher ist ist dass die
sicherheitspolitische situation in
europa sich durch neue herausforderungen
risiken und bedrohungen sicher nicht
verbessert hat ganz im gegenteil es ist
komplexer geworden und sehr vieles ist
kaum vorhersehbar
angesichts des sich rasch verändern und
sich als politischen umfeldes muss die
europäische union ihre strategische
agenda laufend evaluieren und anpassen
ja und ein beispiel dafür ein beispiel
dafür ist die ausarbeitung des
strategischen kompasses der europäischen
union dieser kompass soll als
sicherheitspolitisches grundlagen
dokument die strategischen ziele und die
interessen der europäischen union im
bereich sicherheit und verteidigung
definieren das strategische kompass soll
als zukünftiges orientierung als
zielrichtung begrüßen haften
entwicklungen dienen es geht darum
festzuhalten welche
fähigkeiten notwendig sind und welche
prioritäten
gemeinsam verfolgt werden sollen um den
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
und bedrohungen begegnen zu können was
ist das ziel und zu diesem ziel da gibt
es vier
hauptthemen bereiche
krisen-management
resilienz fähigkeiten und
partnerschaften der zweck dieses
strategischen kompasses ist es die eu
globale strategie aus dem jahr 2016 also
das wesentlichste strategische
grundlagen dokument europäischen union
zu konkretisieren und in eine
spezifischere strategie für die
gemeinsame sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
zu übersetzen das heißt dass
strategische kontos der zielt auf die
abwendung von hybriden bedrohungen ab
und ausländische einflussnahme hin der
kompass soll zum frühzeitigen erkennen
von bedrohungen und krisen beitragen und
somit an der entwicklung einer
gemeinsamen strategischen vision für die
europäische verteidigungspolitik
mitwirken es gibt dazu eine 360°
bedrohungsanalyse und wir also
österreich unterstützt neben anderen
staaten dabei den ansatz dass diese 360°
bedrohungsanalyse einem periodischen
update unterzogen werden soll und
jeweils aktualisierten erkenntnisse
daraus auch in den jeweiligen strategien
berücksichtigt werden müssen wichtig ist
aber vor allem eines wichtig ist eines
das wir nicht immer wieder neue
dokumente ausarbeiten sondern dass wir
diese auch entsprechend umsetzen um die
sicherheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
gewährleisten zu können und daher auch
ganz deutlich gesagt die europäische
union muss endlich aufhören nur über die
gemeinsame sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik zu reden sondern
wir müssen
endlich damit beginnen für die
sicherheit der bevölkerung zu sorgen um
diesen wichtigen zukunftsberuf es zu
begleiten hat mein ressort gemeinsam mit
nationalen und internationalen
expertinnen und experten ihm
zusammengearbeitet
ja und die heute vorgestellte
publikation die begleitet und sie
resümiert diesen kompass prozess sie
beinhaltet sowohl eine beurteilung von
internationalen expertinnen und experten
über den prozess wie auch deren
einschätzung hinsichtlich der
erfolgsaussichten
ich meine dass dieses buch ein beispiel
ist ein beispiel für die moderne
sicherheitspolitische zusammenarbeit wir
beziehen nämlich eine unabhängige
aussicht in unsere überlegungen mit ein
und es ist mir wirklich ein besonderes
bedürfnis mich zu bedanken
stellvertretend für die externe
beitragsleistung bei ihnen sehr geehrte
frau
universitätsprofessorin als vertreterin
unserer kooperationspartner vielen dank
für die gute ausgezeichnete
zusammenarbeit die wirklich produktiv
auch das ergebnis in diesem buch findet
man danke ich aber auch einen
expertinnen und experten der direktion
verteidigungspolitik und internationale
beziehungen und ich bin schon sehr
gespannt wie der leiter herr brigadier
dr peter vorhofer seine einschätzungen
damit uns allen teilen wird vielen dank
wildhüter abreagieren
bundesminister meine damen und herren
herzlichen dank und einen schönen guten
morgen auch von meiner seite danke dass
wir die gelegenheit haben dieses
produkte und unsere einschätzungen ein
bisschen näher darzulegen
wenn wir über diesen strategischen
compper sprechen müssen wir sagen wir
haben jetzt eine zwischenbilanz
ja also der prozess ist noch nicht zu
ende und er ist auch ergebnisoffen er
bietet aber für die europäische union
wirklich eine sehr große chance nämlich
die handlungsfähigkeit zu erhöhen und im
endeffekt bedeutet es auch den
europäischen bürger mehr zu schützen und
besser zum stützen im positiven sinne
wäre das strategische kompass doch ein
meilenstein der gegenseitigen
kooperation ja also das gegenseite
zusammenarbeiten diesen verteidigung von
sicherheitspolitischen feld noch noch
mehr zu stärken und zu forcieren es ist
auch so dass wir die gsv damit
konkretisieren was heißt dass wir haben
20 16 so und die globale strategie und
wir brauchen so zum jetzt ein dokument
ist es auf den punkt bringt was wir
jetzt konkret noch weitermachen also
ganz wichtig in diesem sinne und es
trägt natürlich auch dazu bei die
sogenannte strategische autonomie in der
europäischen union zu erhöhen
und die handlungsbereitschaft der
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten zu verstärken
also den willen sich überhaupt daran zu
beteiligen also ganz ein wichtiger
aspekt
folge davon ist dass wir auch die
fähigkeiten und kapazitäten erhöhen
müssen beziehungsweise anpassen müssen
und wir dann damit entscheiden können
wann wo und mit welchen partnern wir
maßnahmen setzen im besten falle steht
am ende dieses prozesses ein
richtungsweisendes produkt
das auch die konzeptionellen
unklarheiten dies im rahmen der
dokumente noch gibt schließen soll und
aufarbeiten soll es wäre nicht korrekt
wenn wir nicht sagen würden dass es auch
gewisse risiken in diesem prozess gibt
zum einen ist das dokument am ende dann
klar und verständlich
verstehen alle was damit gemeint ist wie
hoch ist das niveau der implementierung
sind alle bereit diese maßnahmen
umzusetzen
ist vielleicht die themenpalette zu
breit also zu viele themen die dann in
der umsetzung und in der
operationalisierung nicht machbar sind
und als letzte tür lich auch die
nationalen partikularinteressen können
wir die sozusagen hintanhalten die
richtung das ende ist noch nicht klar
aber bei aller ableitungen lassen sich
schon durch für das eine und sie wissen
dass wir haben ein konfrontativer
geopolitisches umfeld wir haben
regionale konflikte um die europäische
union und wir haben sozusagen residenz
gefährte extremereignisse die sozusagen
auf die europäische union und ihre
staaten eintreffen eines ist aber klar
alleine geht es nicht mehr das heißt
also ein ganz ganz großer bad sollte
sich damit beschäftigen oder ziel wäre
es dass
kooperationen zum grund prozess und
grundprinzip der verteidigungspolitik
wird ohne den wirt es sozusagen in
zukunft ganz schwierig sein die
herausforderungen zu lösen und sie
wissen alle die sicherheit der
europäischen union hängt massiv mit der
sicherheit österreichs zusammen daher
ist es wichtig und hat eine
dementsprechende relevanz auch für
österreich was am ende dieses prozesses
heraus kommt
wichtig ist dass wir mitgestalten das
machen wir mehr oder weniger tagtäglich
eines das sozusagen bekannt wird wie es
jetzt zum beispiel diese publikation ja
wo wir die
expertenmeinungen aufarbeiten und
darstellen aus unserem hause und es ist
im grunde genommen eine große chance der
europäischen union
zu einem ernster nehmen akteur in der
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik zu
werden im rahmen der globalen
gemeinschaft für mich persönlich gibt es
zwei dinge die ganz ganz wichtig sein
dass ein ist bleiben die mitgliedstaaten
also begleiten sie und seien sie zum
teil dieses prozesses und das zweite das
für mich noch wichtiger ist
identifizieren sich damit also im grunde
muss rauskommen dass dieses dokument ein
produkt der mitgliedstaaten ist sie
müssen sie damit identifizieren das ist
ganz ganz wichtig daher ein von mir aus
der zeit sehr positive einschätzung aber
wir müssen auch realistisch ist
natürlich darauf schauen es kann auch
nachbesserungen geben müssen wie gesagt
ende des prozesses ist dann in der
französischen präsidentschaft im ersten
halbjahr 20 22 und dort wird sozusagen
dann der schlussstrich gezogen was uns
ermöglicht auch vielleicht liegen nach
dem sommer 22 einem vergleich zu machen
was jetzt die experten geschrieben haben
und was dann sozusagen herausgekommen
ist ja und sie sollen sehen dass unser
haus so zu massiv und dem beteiligt ist
und mitarbeiter am ende möchte mir aber
nutzer meiner mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern sehr herzlich bedanken
die sozusagen hier viel arbeit
hineingesteckt
herzlichen dank und frau bundesminister
danke
herzlichen dank bitte frauen
universitätsprofessorin einen schönen
guten morgen auch von mir und vielen
herzlichen dank für die einladung und
die möglichkeit hier als vertreterin der
nationalen kooperationspartner des bmf
auszusprechen und auch als vertreterin
der österreichischen wissenschafts
community hier dabei zu sein warum ist
dieser prozess ist ethischen kompass für
österreich wichtig nun die grundlagen
dokumente die österreichische
sicherheitsstrategie sowie die teil
strategie verteidigungspolitik
definieren die europäische union als den
zentralen rahmen der österreichischen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik das
wird auch im aktuellen
regierungsprogramm unterstrichen und das
strategische kompensiert zu sehen als
ein zwischenstaatliches institutionelles
bestreben sicherheitsbedrohungen
gemeinsam einzuschätzen strategische
ziele im rahmen der gsvp zu definieren
und auf diese hinzuarbeiten
es geht aber nicht nur um militärische
fähigkeiten sondern ganz zentral um
einen politisch strategischen prozess
der willensbildung zu der frage wer oder
was möchte die eu in zukunft im bereich
sicherheit und verteidigung sein und
hier gilt es trotz der großen
unterschiedlichkeiten der
mitgliedstaaten in diesem bereich ein
gemeinsames verständnis zu entwickeln
wenn die eu weiterhin eine gestaltende
rolle in der welt spielen möchte und
österreich kann selbstverständlich von
so einem prozess nicht ausgeschlossen
sein wollen
es gibt zahlreiche beispiele für
neuartige bedrohungen
klimawandel cupid pandemie terrorismus
die stabilisierende technologien
desinformationskampagne aber auch
traditionelle bedrohungen wie die
stabilisierungs gefahren in der
europäischen nachbarschaft am beispiel
ukraine konflikt haben wir das gesehen
das wirkt sich alles direkt und
unmittelbar vor zwei sicherheitslage aus
und darum ist es essentiell dass
österreich sich solidarisch und
sicherheitspolitische prozesse in der eu
einbringt und gemeinsam mit den anderen
mitgliedsstaaten hier einen beitrag
leistet die
expertinnen und experten die zu der
erwähnten publikationen beigetragen
haben unter anderem meine kollegen und
kolleginnen am oeg verreist verweisen
darauf dass es hier zusammenhalt und ein
deutliches bekenntnis zu europa geben
muss um diesen prozess zu stärken
insbesondere in einer zeit in der die
europäische glaubwürdigkeit immer wieder
in frage gestellt wird für ein
verstärktes österreichisches engagement
eignen sich meiner einschätzung nach
besonders die arbeits körbe resilienz
und partnerschaften die südliche und
östliche eu nachbarschaft sollte der
regionale schwerpunkt sein generell
sollten wir unsere tradition als
neutraler staat folgend unsere
vermittelnde rolle ausspielen wir sind
immerhin ein standort vieler
internationaler organisationen unter
anderem der un und osze wir sind ein
gewichtiger partner der nato wir sind
damit ein zentrum des multilateralismus
und der regelbasierten internationalen
ordnung und das gilt es in einem prozess
des strategischen kompass einzubringen
abschließend möchte ich unterstreichen
was die frau bundesministerin schon
gesagt hat die zusammenarbeit zwischen
ministerien internationalen expertinnen
und experten und auch österreichischen
forschern und forscherinnen ist aus
meiner sicht für die gestaltung moderner
sicherheitspolitik unumgänglich nur mit
diesen unterschiedlichen perspektiven
und im austausch dieser perspektiven
können wir eine gesamtheitliche
betrachtungsweise der traditionellen
aber besonders auch der nicht
traditionellen sicherheitsbedrohungen
erlangen und ich denke dass diese art
der kooperation die wir hier schon lange
pflegen und die sich jetzt auch
ausdrückt in diesem werk auch ein modell
sein kann für andere politikbereiche
daher bedanke ich mich noch einmal ganz
herzlich für die komplementären
wissensgenerierung prozess den wir hier
geschafft und die ausgezeichnete
zusammenarbeit dann bedanke ich mich
sehr herzlich willkommen und beendet die
pressekonferenz dankeschön